kyle gibson one of the acquisitions of
the
rangers in the offseason coming over
from the minnesota twins takes the mount
tonight second
start against the athletics in this
20-20 season started against them
back on august the 5th and no decision
all right marcus is going to
check in 96 94 outside that one
lined into right field a base hit for
simeon
he'll go for two as gallow manages the
bounces down in that right field corner
which at times can be
challenging now canna hitting 290 three
homers
20 rbis he had the first inning hit
yesterday to drive in a run
high fly ball center field long run out
there for tavares but he gets to it
cannon just missed hitting one out john
manley on the mount for
the athletic six wins against the
rangers which is good he's one of his
last
five so two out bottom of the first
there's no score here's joey gallo who's
been scuffling
that one cute up the third base line
heim picks it up it's a fair ball he
froze in time to get gallow
tears trevino one out bottom of the
second he is in the rangers nothing
nothing
the one two and trevino hits this ball
hard out to left field that'll be extra
bases
one hops the fence jose heads to second
base and he's in there with a double
trevino able to go from second to third
and so charinos is out four
three two away and that'll bring up
isaiah connor falloffa
let's just pull hard up the middle base
hit and that'll get the first run home
tonight
trevino in from third connor philippa
cashes in
and the rangers have the one nothing
lead cal gibson's issued back to back
walks here to begin the
top of the third inning so nine pitches
in the inning and that's just his second
strike bouncer to third they'll go to
second one the relay
in time double play
around the horn they go five four three
and that's a huge break for kyle gibson
grossman awaits a two-strike pitch
target set up inside and here it comes
and that's a breaking ball in the dirt
gets away from the catcher
charinos here comes kemp headlong slide
and he's in safely with a tying run
so that big lead and that set up
defensively by the rangers allowed tony
to really get down the line for that
very moment
so matt chapman to lead it off here in
the top of the fourth against kyle
gibson it's a one-on-one
matt gameplay turned enough out of the
way but it definitely got some of him
and he's going to be
attended to now by head athletic trainer
nick paparesta
and bob melvin the a's manager out there
as well near the batter's box he's just
hoping that it might have grazed him
right on the ear flap the front ear flap
yep gibson showing some class
checks with chapman who looks like he's
okay
now canna and he'll roll one down to
third base frazier goes to second they
get the out there the relay
oh not in time olson singled his last
time up one won the score two outs of
runner at first
that one's hit deep to right center
field forget about it
that baby's gone it's his tenth of the
year
it comes with a man on and the a's now
lead a three to
one the smooth stroke of matt olson and
he
unloads on gibson back with the 2-2
and the swing and a missed change up
away that time and frazier gone on
strikes and that is
the second strikeout for sean nobody on
a's leading three to one the a's trying
for a shutdown inning
santana pops it up behind second base
so it should be a good inning for sean
monae and it
here's marcus who's doubled and bounced
into a five four three double play the
years lead three to one over the rangers
top half of the fifth
that balls hit high in the air to left
field solac going back
solik at the wall that baby's gone and
simeon has hit it out and these take a
five to one lead
in their second long ball this evening
in arlington
and for marcus it's number five
here's chorinos and torinos gets hit
so robinson torino is hit by a pitch
probably not
super thrilled about that well he thinks
he was hit intentionally because
he has hit a couple been hit a couple of
times and now the umpires are huddling
and they're warning both benches so
there must have been the sense that
there might have been
at least a hint of intent there
i don't think he's trying to put one on
base grounded a shortstop
and simeon can't get a clean handle on
it
everybody's safe what may well be that
that hit batter
starts a critical rally in this fifth
inning so we'll see what solace can do
here
with rangers all over the bases there
they go
3-2 pitch lined into right field and
that one is
trapped two runs will score
solac with a base hit to right and he
makes it a 5-3 ball game
five three a's they're threatening
runners at the corners
bounce toward frazier frazier's going to
come home kemp's going to be in a run
down
the throw back and kemp is safe somehow
tony contorted his body with a dive and
got the right hand on the bag
as frazier missed the tag and everybody
is safe
that one not close ghostman walks with
the bases loaded the a's will take it at
six to three
comes set and the pitch to kenna runners
go here it comes look at it hit him a
slider backed up and it hit him that'll
get the a's another run forced in with
the hit by pitch and it's 7-3 oakland
jimmy herchit comes on in relief to face
stephen piscotti a's up 7-3
that's a base hit left field simeon's
going to score
grossman's going to score here comes
mark canna and this one is going to
clear the bases a
three-run double for piscotti and that
makes it a five-run inning
so two away here in the night he's
trying to wrap it up
[Applause]
right demarcus simeone this should do it
the throw across
is in time and that will do it so the
a's bounce back
after a frustrating loss last night and
they even up the series
and a game of peace